[Music]
three two one action
oh hey welcome back to off-the-record
we're talking about what are the [ __ ]
one whatever we want
hell we want
and today we've got Nelson here hey
[Applause]
pretty I miss the vigilante how about
yourself
Oh beautiful beautiful man you guys want
to get a room like yeah can i watch okay
yeah we can all watch we can all take it
over there actually then no I just want
to hear about him ooh and hear what you
were about - I'm gonna hear my eyes I
wanna hear your eyes and see your
thoughts and taste ears ears do I now
so what point did you realize you are
the baby of the group as in like the
adorable baby you are sunshine at what
point did you realize he's 14 a virgin
[Applause]
write in the comments happy birthday
back they did oh yeah Nelson's an editor
for us he does a variety of editing is
for news he has her party he helps out
on party - he's a camera operator it's a
little bit of jack-of-all-trades and
it's a manly man that builds motors I
build motorcycles and stuff yeah so what
I guess uh what what would you consider
your role in the company what you do is
like a job okay cheery but he says sad
things that a cheery one loves puns not
that secret I know as I like that a lot
a lot of things too like how like sad
music but in a happy tone you know what
I mean so you like each other what look
why it's sad but I mean it's kind of
well it's like more mellow than its
mellow oh boy maybe even somber that's
yeah that's on the sad side work it out
yeah now we're all sad Josh ah good
we're all like 300 but yeah like like
like I don't know I like songs that like
touch on topics that are the opposite
was a way to sound like the way we'd
expect right so like oh sorry if you
don't listen any other words you're like
oh this is it it's a bomb it's like
they're like oh this is about kids dying
Oh discovering that it does it's about
yeah did you like all the nursery rhymes
and growing up my [ __ ]
the kindergarten I'll just turn that on
Oh about that Humpty Dumpty doe suicide
no wait no yeah a great fall I could be
alone purpose we all know you gotta
bother me motorcycle enthusiast is this
yes correct great miss a beat it'll even
get why you're like hey here's the thing
when I keep talking I'm I just I just
like Nelson and I know a lot of stuff
about and that I want you guys to know
to sew clothes on motorcycles yeah but
also motorcycles don't ride though this
is what happened yeah right yeah yeah
I'll show you
[Applause]
you gotta be beautiful yeah yeah like I
like bikes
I like bikes more now than I did before
I broke my weight didn't you do like a
charity service involving like I did I
did a distinguished gentleman is right
and you helped me she promo witty do you
yeah I know so what's it about it's uh
they teamed up with the Movember
foundation you guys know moment from
Movember yeah it's particular cancer
prostate cancer mental health awareness
all the problems and there's no more
those are those three
you heard of other problems I think we
can solve the motorcycle right meet
about it then it's not a problem
you're about to stitch it there probably
potentially not now's the time fill that
void oh yeah oh yeah I'm not a composer
come on Kyle all sound is the same sound
so basically it's like an international
thing they have in every country it's
pretty pictures in like South Africa in
like like countries that you wouldn't
even think that would have the resources
to host a ride with a bunch of people
raising money like even in Vietnam where
like you never see bikes but all of us
into all these classic bikes of how in
Vietnam like writing/reading like you
know what made you like one I guess it
sounds like like a pretty big that thing
or the bikes and gentlemen all the time
wants to do it but like I didn't I don't
know I wasn't as diverse in to bike
culture as I am now like this past year
I got like really immersed in it only
this past year yeah building but I have
a story that was way over here I wasn't
like in Dubai so I wrote it you know I
wrote it as a transportation hey that
makes sense cuz I rode for nine years
and like while I respect my culture and
I like I apply a lot of different things
from it I'm not the group right type of
person either way I got to search out I
think like bikes are just like when
people have cars right and like most
people have cars they just drive it they
don't know how to change dough in oil or
anything that's me that's what I hate
the new look like a lot of the newer
motorcycle especially around colleges
that get it and treat it like a car
because it's like cuz there's a lot of
natural respect between bikes but more
people are into it
comes less of like this cult thing that
everybody not has like no Z's like rules
for and stuff right yeah I had a ride
yeah yeah yeah like um but then I
started getting into it this year
because of the fact that I had Macedon
because I started getting into it a
little bit more last fall and then I
broke my arm
and it was like but how how did you fit
go finish this story he's almost broke
your arm yeah your bike was no longer
usable yeah it got totaled yeah repairs
were just all over the page but it
happened like a month after I got my
bike so I got one hobby back it was
great
no no money oh my gosh my god it's
pretty expensive man loving to ride
bikes yeah yeah well I guess I told
myself that if I wanted to ride badly
enough
I would like have to dive in completely
and this was one you know like I'm so
like I told myself if I was gonna get a
bike again instead of buying some nice
expensive like I would try to build my
own bike you did that did yeah what kind
of like to you right for their people
out there right now yeah it's a Honda GL
500 it's a Silver Wing 1982 how long did
it take you to make that oh no cuz he
bought it used
Oh built it at the factory they're like
yeah we got 1982 parts hanging around I
guess you just build it is more of a
traditional I turned into a cafe racer
there you go yeah true and true cafe
racer like buy the book as much as
possible and what that is it's like if
you take an old bike you strip it down
as much as possible to make it light
make it perform really well so that was
like that was the two main things I
wanted to do and I have the look of the
cafe racer too so yeah I was like if I'm
gonna do this I have to want it badly
enough we have to go out buy a used bike
learn how to build one you learned a lot
cool things I learned a lot of cool
things you know how to weld now Thomas
like I learned how to weld before like
jumping into that Josiah like I got my
skills necessary so it's it's yeah yeah
well I learned a lot icicles in the
front so also you say it once so you
only gonna say it once no ask you about
it ever again okay I was riding home
from the optometrist and they told me I
was blind but yeah what do the doctor
did adult things you could write after
lasik right I want what the Forester
forces one with me good and they say
like the most dangerous time to ride is
when you're not like not scared I guess
if you're too comfortable once once
you're too comfortable the bike then
you're not always traveling around for
like what could go wrong you know then
you were too comfortable
let's do comfortable like other but yeah
going home with my glasses
[Laughter]
and then yeah I was going and then I
didn't I didn't see this group of cars
stopped in front of me because they were
making a left turn
you aren't wearing her glasses I know I
don't know they tell it no tell them
what you were looking at oh yeah so the
car that packed in the left side was a
truck utility truck yeah took it like
this rainbow thing
wells I whoa that's interesting yeah
another floor again I'm like oh [ __ ]
they all all these cars stopped and then
I couldn't stop in time yeah I hit the
back yeah no and maybe open the back of
that truck I should have followed the
truck problem right Jesus
and then this guy and then I called Rach
calls me and I was about to leave to go
to a work thing and then I get this
causing nelson's calling me that's weird
what if it's about work oh hey what's up
he's like hey what are you doing right
now I'm about to go to a work thing
about to drive down to like know you I
think you said you something in an hour
or something yeah in an hour I was gonna
go down till you do save work or
anything yeah he's like oh yeah I'm
leaving in there like semantics keep it
going I probably would've hung up on you
my god what for the people it was
work-related I had to go do something so
then for legal reasons he needs you to
know that it was just to make sure
still going through insurance right now
but so so then he was lazy as leeks how
important is that our do you I don't
like why
well what's up he's like I just got into
a motorcycle accident in that exact oh
yeah yeah so yeah cuz they're not I
didn't want I'm like I didn't want to
call people in like bother them
I'll just try calling somebody like
somebody else somebody else and I call
Ryan he's like oh yeah he's like oh yeah
I'm free for the next hour I was like oh
that's cool can you drive me to like the
hospital because I bet firefighters that
might have broken my arm it was like a
fracture and the bone still held
together but it was a fracture so it was
just super swollen yeah and then my legs
were messed up to something I don't know
who else could be wrong and it's
hopefully when you say messed up you
mean look it's like it was pretty bad my
ankle remember yeah it was like bleeding
it was like serious well they're like
whooping all over the so was Marion
there no I didn't tell her until I came
home yeah no you didn't learn then you
learned with me that's why I learned
yeah yeah so jump back in time for
program Nelson was still a dumb-dumb
yeah and then III high-sided with my I
had a sport bike at the time I remember
that one day after raining and then I
high-sided and what high setting means
low siding is when you are turning I
guess or you're honest it's when you
fall and you go on land behind the bike
landing on the back of the bike slides
away from you
high siding is when the bike flips
forward and you flip in front of it oh
yeah pretty crazy and then unfortunately
I decided right when I hit the ground I
called Marion on the Bluetooth of my
head on my helmet I was like hey oh I
got the knives in front of the house
could you come out whatever and she came
out and like crying in tears like I was
gonna die and then after that I learned
for the second accident
I have to not tell her until after I get
home from the hospital today she's like
oh no I'm worried about you not like are
you dead right now let me paint a
picture here because this is what I came
into this scenario and so I got a call
from Nelson
hey man I'm just editing you know check
here right now what's up oh um you
almost finished or is it doing a diner I
was like hey you you know how to ride a
bike you know how to ride a motorcycle
right and I was like yeah why he goes
well I got an accent and uh sorry if
you're on my bike home it looks rideable
me and Marion got it to the parking lot
but she can't ride and I'm someone to
get her back up the hill into my house
and I was like you're you got an accent
you didn't go hospital what the [ __ ] you
guys no no no that's it's fine we're
good we're good just Just Ducky come
help me this time he needed to go to the
hospital I didn't do that stuff how's
this bruised up you yeah you you weren't
bruised up or any night you were brute
you were bruised up but nothing was
broken at that
but here's all I see is a frustrated
Marion just like this when I roll up I'm
like oh this doesn't look good don't
call your girlfriend which isn't good
advice but yeah to do a situation that
works cuz I was like so I was like oh my
god so I was like stay right there I'll
just get whatever thing I'm doing next
like this is important so that like I
rushed up to like Pasadena or he like
fallen over I was like and I found him
and I was like hey buddy how you doing
he's like okay my arms broken
okay so then we're trying to figure out
the next step is like all right he's not
in immediate danger we need to figure
out where we can take him because his
insurance is only gonna cover certain
things don't get health net man don't
get out there like and get good health
insurance we're getting a motorcycle
reals for yes yes so we called the we
called the his health insurance and
we're talking this lady and this lady
picked up the phone she's like hi
welcome calling hi I'm actually calling
on behalf of my friend who just got in a
motorcycle accident and then Nelson from
the you know seat of my cards like oh my
god um I was like I just need to figure
out where the nearest labor that I can
take him to these coverage so oh my god
um I just hang on real quick I'm gonna
get I'm gonna get you right on it I just
okay I'm gonna hold for no more than
five minutes and just like puts me on
hold and I'm like oh yes all the time
what was funny was a remember I was
calling my lip and Casals yeah before I
called Ryan I think I was just I needed
somebody driving the hospital and I
called my other friend and he didn't
pick up at the time and he called me
back and he was like what's going on
blah blah I was like this guy's got the
motors are guys and in my heart I think
my my broken and he's like stop starting
so cheery it's not big deal like yeah
you could come out whatever but like
Ryan
driving me now so you don't need to come
out it's fine and I'm just sitting here
in the driver's seat just like what the
[ __ ] is going so we figure out a place
to take him so I take him and I were
like walks like he's like trying to
punch in his leg
I liked insurance code into the thing
he's like I think that's my thing if you
are just hopped up on adrenaline at this
point you know it started to hurt a lot
so start to wear off well they feel like
an hour later where Ryan finally got to
me anyways so I dumped my guts to the
urgent care was like what an hour and a
half hours in so yeah I was like I was
like man he was just like oh my legs in
a lot of pain come off and then I think
Beach I was eating in the area already
so then I was like I gotta go to my
thing now I can still make it if Beach I
can like stuff yeah so we just you know
tagged out I love are you okay yeah I'm
fine like they're people here now I
think I'm not gonna die like okay I'm
gonna go don't do anything dumb he's
like I'll just wait for Brandon to get
here did you Obama did I see Braddock
over the other foot
don't ride motorcycles Melton yeah
and then Brandon kept saying to me every
day over the next year it still says it
to you that's true
have you ridden the motorcycle since
then they're not the same person I mean
I promised myself when I first started
writing that one accident I was done
okay so I had to sell it nine years
that's crazy yeah but don't anything
yeah actually after when I high-sided I
didn't ride again for like six months
but the problem - a lot of times we take
a long break is that you lose a lot of
like the skill and the like what -
remember when you ride and you have to
force yourself to get back on it because
otherwise like yeah you can't let that
fear beating into you so I had a
neighbor yeah he lived right behind my
house I was like the duplex kind of
situation and he's missing a finger
right and what happened was he was
cleaning his chain and you're not
supposed to clean your chain with you
like a rag in your hand if it's running
like that's just a rule of thumb because
it doesn't stop the chain doesn't stop
yeah so then the rag gets stuck and it
pulls his finger in it pops right off
because it's ring right that was no no
rag he I got caught I thought okay back
on no I mean it grind it in this yeah no
no he had in in gear that's up supplying
throttle yeah that's a problem oh and
he's a professional rider too and he
went to the hospital and within a week
or two after going to the hospital he
was riding again because he told himself
like if I don't get on now I might not
get on again I'm just hopped on within
two weeks with a missing finger
howdy throttling in love it's crazy and
that's energy who you aspire to be
hiding accident it was after taking a
break for like six months before that
just because life was like it was hard I
didn't have time or like the energy to
get fixed up and ride it again so it was
my first day I spent a whole day fixing
the bike up again put a new battery
fresh new battery and then you're not
used to how the bike feels anymore
and it was a super smart bike so it's
like if you don't know how strong
is coming out of a turn if this flies
out dude yeah so now I'm like I think I
have a rule now if I ever get a sport
bike again like something like that
without much power yeah
only if it's like modern electronics
traction control everything at least
until I get used to riding get better
again I'm talking as responsible as
possible now guys and that's the
takeaway from this yeah not stop riding
this ride Maurice no it's all right
motorcycles you know ride more respond
to fares learn you learned about your
gear layabouts to go fast
don't die fast Anita hmm have you got
other aspirations don't do it yeah
especially if your body to do your job
that's tough editing JK news
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]